hi this is mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math tutor to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so we're going to talk about
in this video is how to find the area of
a region using rectangles and this is
going to be a more challenging example
if you want to see some of the other
examples that i did i'll have a link
over there in the card section so you
can check out that video but this one
can be a little bit more challenging but
follow along and you'll understand how
it works so what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be dividing up okay
this region here below this curve and in
between the x-axis so our function here
is f of x equals x cubed plus 2 and
we're going to be finding the area of
the region between one and three okay
below the curve and above the x-axis so
I've shaded that region right here now
what we want to do is we want to find
out okay the width of the rectangles and
the height of the rectangles so what
it's like doing it's like subdividing
this region up into rectangles like this
sometimes this is called the right
rectangular approximation method the are
our am okay and so what I'm doing is I'm
just right now I'm just sub dividing it
into four rectangles just to show you
what we're doing here now when you take
B minus a that's this is the B value
over here on the right and this is the a
value over here on the left so when we
take B minus a that's giving us this
total distance which is going to be too
okay so we have two and we're dividing
it by n so if n is for that means that
we're going to have four rectangles and
that's going to give us to force which
is one half that's going to be the width
of each rectangle okay so you're with me
so far now over here the B minus a
divided by n is the same as this it's
the width of each rectangle times I and
what's I I is our index okay we're
starting from 1 and we're going to end
the number of rectangles that we're
working with okay and so what you're
going to do is you're going to start at
the left side of the region in this case
is going to be at one okay and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
move
one with c2 over and I one with to the
right and then you're going to put this
x value into your function for X and
that's going to give you your Y value
which is the height okay so we're
putting this quantity into our function
in place of X to get our height now as I
increases say as I goes to to your
starting at one now you're going over 12
widths and then you put that value in
your getting the height of that
rectangle when I is three you're going
over three widths and you're going up
and that's giving you the height of that
rectangle and so on and by summing these
up okay summing them up we're going to
be finding out the sum of all the
individual rectangles we're going to be
approximating the area now if you take
the limit as n goes to infinity look
what happens here this is going to be
getting thinner and thinner smaller and
smaller until it just becomes paper-thin
you're going to have an infinite number
of rectangles you're going to get the
exact area underneath the curve okay so
you're with me so far so this is the the
power of limits and this is getting us
into what calculus starts to get into at
the beginning so what we're going to do
now is let's go ahead and keep
proceeding with this example this a
little bit more challenging just some of
the arithmetic but i just want to show
you how it works because so many
students get a little bit tripped up on
some of the details so we're going to
put 1 plus 2 over n I in for X ok so
let's go over here give ourselves some
more room so this is going to be 1 plus
2 I over N cubed plus 2 ok and that's
all x 2 over N ok now you see how this
is a binomial two terms so we're going
to use is we're gonna use the binomial
expansion theorem Pascal's triangle and
if you remember Pascal's triangle looks
like this right 11 12 11 33 1 and what
we're gonna do is we're going to go down
to this third row this is rose 0 1 2 3
we're gonna go down to the third row to
help us expand this third degree
binomial so this is going to be 1331 and
then this is going to be the first term
is going to be one
cubed 1 squared 1 to the first and one
to the zero and the second term is going
to be 2 I over N to the zero and we're
going into ascending order so to I over
N to the first to I over N to the second
and two I over N to the third okay and
all these terms are going to be added
together okay remember this is still
plus two and it's still being multiplied
by two over N okay so here with me so
far so we're just going to simplify so
anything that is your power is 1 1 cubed
is 1 times 1 is 1 so that it was pretty
easy this is going to be 1 squared is 1
times 3 is 3 times 2 is going to give us
six I over N okay over here we've got 2
squared is 4 times 3 is 12 so that gives
us 12 I squared over N squared okay plus
one to the 0 is 1 times 1 is 1 2 cubed
is 8 I cubed over n cubed plus 2 okay
now i see this 2 and this one let's just
go ahead and combine those let's make us
three okay all times 2 over N now what
we're going to do is we're just going to
take the two around we're going to
distribute it to each term okay like
that so we get 6 over n plus 12 I over N
squared plus 24 I squared over N cubed
plus 16 I cubed over n to the fourth now
along the way here you can see I drop
this summation sign but really want to
carry that through the problem so these
are all being summed okay up from i
equals 1 to n this whole quantity but
what we're going to do now is we're
going to split these up into separate
summations okay so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to write this as 6 over n
plus the sum of twelve I over N squared
plus the sum of 24 I squared over N
cubed plus the sum of 16 I cubed over n
to the fourth okay now what you can do
is you can bring you know in front of
the summation this
here you can think of this term is a
constant we're just going to leave the I
okay and to the right of the summation
so we're going to bring these guys in
front okay and just to kind of get them
out of the way so this is going to be 6
over N ok 1 plus 12 over N squared which
is going to be I this is going to be 24
/ n cubed which is I squared okay and
then this is going to be 16 / n to the
fourth I cubed so now I'm sure in your
math book your teacher probably showed
you the formulas for all these okay
summations like the sum of consecutive
integers or some of consecutive squares
of some of consecutive cubes I'm going
to do those substitutions now so if you
were to add up one plus one plus one
plus 1 n times that's going to give you
n so this is going to be n times 6 over
N the ends cancel so we get 6 okay over
here we have I okay that's going to be n
times n plus 1/2 okay and you can see
this ad in this end cancel the 12 and
the to reduce down so we get 6 n plus 6
over N so six n plus 6 all over N okay
over here we get 24 / n cubed times n
times n plus 1 times 2n plus 1 all
divided by 6 and you can see the six in
the 24 reduced that's for one of these
ends cancels with one of these leaving n
squared and if we foil this out a little
bit further we get 2n squared plus 3n
plus one and if we distribute the 4
we're getting eat n squared + 12 + + 4
all divided by N squared okay plus the
last one here 16 let's put it over here
16 / n to the fourth times N squared n
plus 1 squared over 4 and you can see
these reduce two of these cancel with
two of these this comes out to N squared
plus 2n plus 1 we distribute the 4 we
get 4 and squared plus 8 + + 4
all / and squared okay so you're with me
so far okay good so now what we're going
to do is going to split these up into
separate fractions okay so i'm just
going to divide each term by the
denominator okay like that i'm just
going to split them up so we've got six
plus six n divided by n is 6 plus 6 over
n plus the N square roots cancel we get
8 plus this is 12 one of these ends in
one of these ends would cancel so that's
going to be 12 / ok n plus 4 over N
squared plus here are the N squared is
going to cancel we get 4 plus 8 n / well
one of these ends is going to cancel
with one of these was 8 over n plus 4
over and squared okay so you're with me
so far so it's it's it's quite a long
process okay but now what we're going to
do is okay we're going to combine like
terms and then what we're going to do is
we're going to look at how many
rectangles do we want to use to
approximate this area do we want to use
for if it's for we're going to put four
in place of N and that will be our
approximate area we want ten rectangles
we put 10 in for n but let's do this
right now just an interest of saving
time let's say we want n to go to
infinity we want there to be an infant
number of rectangles infinitely thin
okay so we can get the exact area
underneath the curve so what we're going
to do is we take the limit as n goes to
infinity so as n goes to infinity six
divided by n as n gets larger larger
this term is going to go to 0 this term
here is going to go to 0 this term here
is going to 0 this term here is going to
0 and this term here is going to 0 so
we'll do what do we have left we have 6
plus 6 is 12 plus 8 is 20 plus 4 is 24
so the exact area of this irregular
shaped region okay below the curve and
in between the x-axis is going to be 24
square units so this is the form you
want to memorize go ahead and take a
look at my past video talking about this
concept a little bit further if you want
additional help and subscribe to the
channel check out some my past videos
and I'll look forward to seeing in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon